i hate to put you on the spot and you
feel free to say no truly jason
do you have a guitar handy and can you
just strum a little bit and just hum
something
as in in the context of you
how you would write a song just just
could you demonstrate this so i would
start
[Music]
to me that sounds a little bit like the
band like levon hill and robbie
robertson that sounds like the night
they drove old dixie down which
convene conveniently
that song has been canceled as it's
about uh the confederacy so what we
should do now if i were writing a song
would be write something to replace the
knight that drilled dixie down
so now i have kind of a subject matter
so i would be like well let's write
something about that war that's not
celebrating the confederacy this is just
what i would do right now and make it
kind of sound like the night they drove
old dixie down um so that's the exercise
is to like write a write a replacement
for that not that i would ever do that
but
[Music]
and here we're changing the melody
a little bit later than we change the
chord because that's how we're creating
tension and release
so like if you're if you're walking down
from the c major
to the relative minor
and you're singing like a five
now if i if i took the melody down at
the same time as the chord change
it becomes piano man that's not what you
want you know you want something that
makes it more tense you know
[Applause]
[Music]
so the part of that sticks out to me
is the
[Music]
so that's the part i would probably
write first i would say
that's the part that's going to stick so
what are those words going to be
and then i would record that so i didn't
forget it
and i would work on
three syllables
you know
short word long word
or three short words
because if you do long word short word
it's gonna sing in a different way than
it speaks and you're cheating
you know and people can hear that when
you're when you're cheating so i would
go short word long word
and then i would start looking for a
short word in a long word that had
something to do
with the reality of
the story that was uh romanticized in
the beautiful song the night they drove
old dixie down by the band